mein heutiger gast ist deutschlands
derzeit erfolgreichste kabarettistin
simone solga sie gewannen den deutschen
kleinkunstpreis 2018 zuvor den deutschen
kabarettpreis und sie ist die
kanzlersouffleuse herzlich willkommen
bei phoenix was bitte macht eine
kanzlersouffleuse eine kanzlersouffleuse
hat ist verbunden mit dem kanzler haben
einen knopf im ohr
also in dem fall die kanzlerin auch wo
sie botschaften der souffleuse bekommt
also vielleicht kleine rede hinweise
vielleicht themenwechsel stichworte
haltungs korrekturen so was das war die
idee für mich als kabarettistin es ist
ganz witzig wäre wenn die durch einen
knopf im ohr verbunden sind und es gibt
einen verwandten von mir
gregor niemand sagen alte bücher der
souffleur von walter ulbrich und da war
das noch neu mit dem suff lehrern und da
hat gregor niemandem ulbrich souffliert
ich habe die absicht eine mauer zu bauen
und der ullrich hat das falsch
verstanden gab in die welt niemand hat
die absicht eine mauer zu bauen und so
gibt es eben auch höher
für heller der souffleur der weltpolitik
so sind sätze entstanden durch uns damit
wir uns da ein bisschen genaues bild
davon machen können schauen wir uns
jetzt einfach mal einen kurzen
ausschnitt aus ihrem programm an das ist
ja so ich komme gerade aus einem
krisengebiet
ja es jeweils sie haben es im fernsehen
die bilder gesehen entsetzen grau und
elend verzweifelte gesichter und
deutschland schaut teilnahmslos zu und
das schlimme finde ich ist diese
hoffnungslosigkeit ja meine damen und
herren ich komme aus dem kanzleramt
aus deutschlands best bewachter
geschlossene abteilung aus dem einzigen
irrenhaus aus dem die irren nicht raus
sollen da sie alle reihen wollen nehmen
sie als beispiel den bärtigen
buchhändler als beispiel jetzt ja unser
mann mit den haaren im gesicht erhält
doch nun wirklich alles gemacht um ins
kanzleramt zu kommen wirklich alles
außer mal ehrlich die wahrheit zu sagen
ein sozialdemokrat der selbst im liegen
noch umfallen kann aber schon ich wollte
gar nicht über die spd sprechen man soll
nicht über tote schlecht reden es ist
nein nein friede ihrer asche die sie
einstreichen für ihre ministerposten
aber haben sie es haben sie mal die
chance haben sie die merkel bei der
schausten gesehen haben sie es gesehen
dieses interview wo sie sagt natürlich
werde ich nicht noch mal zwölf jahre
bundeskanzler aber 4
haben sie das schon verarbeitet ich kann
nicht mehr eine frau die hier auf dem
land liegt wieder sarkophag von
tschernobyl stabile fassade keinerlei
bewegung egal wie es darunter brodelt
verstehen sie die ist doch wieder mauer
schwamm die krallt sich ans kanzleramt
und keiner kriegt aus der bausubstanz
ja
ich darf wieder aufregen würde ich hab
ja gar nicht sagt bin ja kein
unschuldslamm ich gebe es ja zu sagen
ehrlich ich habe ja ja mitgemacht ich
habe ja gearbeitet im kanzleramt
mitgemacht erarbeitet für das regime im
geheim
ja ich war bis gestern merkels willige
helferin merkels rechte hand damit ist
jetzt schluss wissen sie wie die morgen
ohne mich da steht so
roche ich kanzlersouffleuse angestellte
flüstertüte doch das zieht einen runter
jeden tag muss ich da mal sagen was ich
sagen soll wenn sie von allein auf
nichts gutes kommt wenn die letzten
jahre aufgepasst haben wissen sie diese
noch nie auch was gutes gekommen also
gehe ich hin und flüstere irgendwas zu
irgendwas was besonnen und nett klingt
muss ja nicht wirklich durchdachte seien
acht menschen wie ihn ein gutes gefühl
simone solga sie waren jahrelang die
kanzlersouffleuse jetzt hat ihre
bühnenfigur gestern gekündigt warum
ja wenn ich mir die geschichte der
souffleuse so anschaue ist es jetzt wohl
an der zeit auch zu sagen es ist gut es
kommt nichts mehr ich habe versucht die
merkel als souffleuse zu spielen
aber wie eine stradivari die bleibt eine
bratsche es macht keinen sinn mehr so
flüssig zu sein und die der logische weg
ist glaube ich mich jetzt auch zu
verabschieden und zu sagen dann ist
jetzt gut frau merkel physikerin ist
auch ein gutes guter job wäre für sie
also ich muss meiner wege gehen für
diese kabarett figur der
kanzlersouffleuse haben sie sich ja ganz
intensiv mit angela merkel
auseinandergesetzt wie wichtig denn
angenommen wird
angela merkel tickt also ist er hatte
eine phase da habe ich gedacht wie toll
wie schlau ist die frau da geht es so um
inhalt das war so sehr es gibt ich habe
einen bekannten auch der ähnliches
muster lebt der ist ganz still da hört
zu und lässt die anderen quatschen und
dann sagt er ganz dosiert einen satz und
der passt und alle sind baff und das hat
die merkel auf wo ich dachte das kann
man sich abgucken privat für sein leben
auch zu hören lass die anderen sich
austoben und dann siehst du ab jetzt
aber reicht das nicht mehr also es ist
es ist nicht genug wir brauchten jetzt
ein kanzler eine kanzlerin die auf den
tisch haut die ordnung schafft die sagt
so und so und die in der linie vorgibt
dass das tut sie nicht und das ist
glaube ich an der wende auch in der
geschichte merkel und sie hat sich ein
bisschen in ihren stand der so brillant
war wo man sagte das ist eine kanzlerin
da konnten fast alle mit leben haben
gesagt die würde ich wieder den hatte
sie ein bissel und ich will dich was
versammelt aber vielleicht geht es jetzt
geschichtlichen anreger aber warum war
sie sind so lange
erfolgreich und warum klappt das jetzt
nicht mehr aus ihrer sicht weil jetzt
mehr gefragt ist von mir also bis zu
verwalten um außenpolitik zu machen ist
das alles ganz vortrefflich gewesen aber
wenn es jetzt so im land brodelt und
unsere gesellschaft so ein riss nimmt
der riss durch die gesellschaft geht und
solche konflikte aufkommen wie jetzt
kennen nicht so und so weiter dann
braucht es jemand der richtig auf den
tisch haut und da ist nicht nur
diplomatie gefragt wie man im ausland
sondern jetzt muss ich hier im land mal
eingreifen
und das kann sie irgendwie nicht oder
wir vermissen ist alle die meisten
kabarettisten machen kabarett aus einer
bestimmten haltung meistens nur linken
haltung heraus welcher haltung machen
sie den kabarett aus der haltung der
souffleuse ein und also als mittelsmann
zwischen kabarettistin so anders als als
souffleuse und dem publikum meine figur
das fand ich damals eine schöne idee ist
ja keine abgehobene die in der politik
in der politik arbeitet und man sagt die
kriegt wie die politiker nichts mehr mit
sondern ich bin eine bürgerin einer von
denen da unten in die durch zufall in
diesem job geraten ist und nun über
beide seiten berichten kann das fand ich
sehr wichtig um nicht arrogant und
abgehoben zu sein und deswegen ist es
das schöne dass man nicht wie andere
kabarettisten über die politiker erzählt
sondern ich kann auch mit ihnen reden in
dem frau merkel am telefon auftaucht und
sowas das ist eröffnet auch diese kleine
diesem kleinen privaten dieses hinter
die kulissen gucken aus dem nähkästchen
plaudern
das ergibt die figur super her und wir
haben und da können sie sich erinnern
hatte dieser uralt bundespräsident der
christian wulff nicht dieser und und die
merkel dann wiederholt hatte sagt der
islam gehört zu deutschland
und da hatte ich damals schon zur merkel
gesagt als welcher islam jetzt habe ich
gefallen gibt ja so viele ich sage frau
merkel immerhin die lebenden muslime
gehören zu deutschland finde ich schon
ich bin immer für eine trennung von
staat und kirche also zu hause kann ja
jeder machen was er will
aber da ist
frau merk aber wenn der islam zu
deutschland gehört dann gehört aber auch
die kritik zum islam zu deutschland
also hat nein islam ist eine religion
wie jeder andere auch man müsse nur
unterscheiden zwischen islam und
islamismus
gut man weiß nie wo fängt das eine an wo
hört das andere auf ja nein aber islam
hat nichts mit islamismus zu tun das ist
klar
alkohol hat ja auch nichts mit
alkoholismus zu tun angst ist ein
schlechter ratgeber frau merkel macht
man sich vor die leute haben auch nicht
die angst aber die sorge dass irgendwie
die meinungsfreiheit hier ein bisschen
über den jordan gegangen ist ja nicht
dass man nicht die freiheit heute alles
zu sagen aber irgendwo wenn es nicht die
meinung des gegenüber spiegelt dann ist
wird man ganz schnell in solche ecken
gesteckt kaum sagen wir mal was
kritisches über muslime oder den islam
oder über flüchtlinge dann ist man oft
gleich rassist oder rechtsradikal oder
nazi oder als steigbügelhalter rechten
also was wir hier treiben merken sie das
ist doch irre
wir müssen mal aufhören mit das ist ja
schlecht für michaela ddr
wir müssen doch über alles offen reden
können und fragen können und in ecken
gesteckt zu werden
verstehen sie wenn dir das thema
ich will den wir das thema nicht offen
wie wir jetzt alle offen besprechen dann
überlassen wir das thema ja wirklich
diesen scheiß nazis die wir alle so
hassen ist das jetzt ihre bühnenfigur
die schwierigkeiten hat mit diesem satz
der islam gehört zu deutschland oder ist
das auch ihre persönliche überzeugung
hier verschämt das ist wohl wahr und die
aufnahme ist jetzt nicht von gestern ist
ein bisschen älter schon aber zeigt ja
wie aktuell das thema ist und natürlich
kommt dann auch als kabarettistin auch
als souffleuse kommt meine meinungen
oder meine ansichten da schon auch ins
programm des erwarten dass ich bin ja
nicht nur eine figur mit vierter band
weit weg sondern das geht schon als
kabarettistin dahin und ich glaube das
ist auch ein thema was die zuschauer
sehr interessiert wo es auch still wird
wo sie wo es auch sehen sie an dem
ausschnitt gar nicht so portiert und
witzig ist oder wo auch mal zeit ist das
anzusprechen ohne dass daten gängen
drauf kommt ansonsten ist mein programm
sehr witzig und heiter es ist bei dem
thema freilich nicht wissen anliegen und
was jetzt in der zeit dieser aufnahme
bis heute daraus geworden ist das sehen
wir jetzt dass es immer noch ein problem
gibt dass sich das radikalisiert bis zu
chemnitz und das macht es eigentlich
immer schlimmer weil wir offen nicht
immer über alles reden können
das sagt ja die kanzlersouffleuse und
damit unterstelle ich sie auch in diesem
kurzen ausschnitt wenn man in
deutschland seine meinung frei und offen
äußert dann wird man sehr leicht in die
rechte ecke gestellt mann gilt als
rassist oder nazi sagen sie ist das
wirklich so
ich denke ja also sagen kann man alles
nicht wie in der ddr
ich werde hier nicht abgeholt und das
ist auch gott sei dank so aber es
passiert eben dass man spießruten läuft
das man vielleicht von verwandten
bekannten kollegen ausgeschlossen wird
das gibt es vielleicht können leute ihre
bilder nicht mehr ausstellen oder leute
können ihre bücher nicht verlegen oder
vielleicht wird die kabarettistin
aufgrund dessen nicht gerne in
irgendeiner gebucht so was kann alles
sein und das ist eine ganz gefährliche
entwicklung die wir
rad durch machen haben sie persönlich
den eindruck oder haben sie das
persönlich erlebt dass sie probleme
haben wenn sie ihre meinung äußern
ich habe mehr zuspruch dafür dass ich
das so sage als ablehnung aber es gibt
durchaus leute die während der
veranstaltung sehr selten aber es
passiert die stehen mittendrin auf und
gehen und klar knallen mit den türen und
sagen dann draußen afd kabarett mit der
afg nichts gemein und ich sage einfach
nur was ich denke oder stelle auch
vieles in frage wie mit dem islam
ich weiß es doch auch nicht und man sagt
dass eben viele formen des islam welche
gehört zu deutschland und wenn der zu
deutschland gehört dann müssen wir auch
alle dann ist er unser problem dann
können wir auch alle über alles
diskutieren das muss möglich sein ohne
zensur sondern dass man fragen stellt
und sagen hat und wenn dann leute gehen
dann wollen sie anderen natürlich zeigen
ich gehe vor der pause ich knall mit den
türen ich bin nicht einverstanden das
passt mir jetzt nicht das soll ja
publikumswirksam sein so ein abgang auch
man kann ja auch bei mir anklopfen mit
mir reden oder so also es gibt viele
leute die das nicht so sehen und die
einen dann so ein bisschen die
haltungsnoten verteilen wollen warum
aber kann ich nicht über alles das nicht
alles ansprechen wenn wir das nicht tun
wir haben das glaube ich auch viel zu
spät angefangen
es ging nach 2 15 los in talkshows wo es
dann immer gleich hieß das leistet den
falschen vorschub und das gießt öl ins
feuer oder das sind diffuse ängste wie
sich die geschichte entwickelt hat sehen
weil diffuse ängste sind es gar nicht
und wenn wirklich ich bin überzeugt wenn
wir nicht diese themen besprechen
beackern
dann geben wir den weg frei für die
leute die wir nun wirklich nicht wollen
die das thema zur sicht zu eigen machen
auf ihrer homepage steht politisch
korrekten es war gestern
das gibt ärger welche probleme haben sie
denn mit politischen correctness ist es
nicht gut dass es dann so eine art
schutzwall gibt gegen hass hetze dieser
unterwegs ist ich weiß nicht wer
bestimmt was wohl der schutz mal anfängt
und was der schutzwall ist hass und
hetze sind ja noch mal ganz was anderes
als wenn ich über dinge reden oder sie
zur frage stelle oder da zeige meinem
programm das ich mir darüber gedanken
machen das hat ja mit hass und hetze nur
noch gar nichts zu tun
das sind ja völlig völlig andere dinge
mit der andere wird mir dann schon sagen
du das
ist jetzt hetze oder hass allem einem
prüfer auch bei den texten die ich mache
schon wenn jetzt jemand im publikum
setzte den das betrifft ein muslim ein
flüchtling wenn es um die systeme
angegeben ob ich das auch sagen würde
selbst der vor mir habe ich das wirklich
so auch in auch sagen würde
und das kann ich bestätigen und die
leute würden furchtbar lachen und würden
wahrscheinlich nach einer meinung sein
das problem machen hier nur einzelne
leute die dann immer alles abklopfen und
sie haben ja oder eine veranstaltung die
sagt ihnen ob sie den falschen manchmal
mit einem thema da geht es um gender und
das sternchen bei den inhalten ob sie
den falschen vorschub leisten nämlich
immer wer sind die falschen wm-leistung
vorschub sitzen nazis in meinem publikum
wusste ich gar nicht also es ist auch
ein bisschen vorhergesagt der vorwurf
sie bekommen beifall von der falschen
seite das geht ja ein bisschen über
ähnliche richtung ja aber was soll ich
jetzt sagen soll nicht schweigen und
dinge nicht ansprechen beifall von einer
falschen seite kommen können dann können
wir aber gar nicht sprechen und klammern
wieder alles aus und dann hat die
falsche seite
das argument und das geht uns nicht
besser es ist quatsch glaube ich über
welche themen kann ihrer ansicht nach
denn in deutschland nicht offen ehrlich
gesprochen werden also flüchtlingskrise
ok islam helfer standen ja betrifft
hauptsächlich dieses thema oder gibt es
noch an der seite seitdem wir diese
probleme oder diese themen an der
tagesordnung haben halten die uns ganz
schön in atem und da geht es in jeder
talkshow in allem immer darum darf ich
das sagt man nicht sonst gelb ist ja
chemnitz nicht wenn es so wäre wenn das
nicht ein problem wäre klar ich gibt
wenig kabarettisten die sagen mal in der
nummer gegen linke oder grüne machen das
wird immer ein bisschen ausgespart und
auch da gibt es ja zu graben oder euch
was zu sagen also es wird schon mal dann
ist es also ich denke mal ist in
systemen die den normalen zuschauer
interessieren die mich auch
interessieren sie anzusprechen und das
ist das ändern das ist wenn eine
hauswand übermalt wird ein gedicht
übermalt wird wenn eine frau sagt sie
möchte die nationalhymne erinnern die
ihr zu männlich ist dann finde ich das
gerade sehr reizvoll
genau
und das auf die bühne zu bringen ich
habe das so verstanden dass sie im
kabarett gerne so die perspektive der
kleinen leute einnehmen also nicht von
oben sondern aus dem publikum heraus was
ist das jetzt wenn sie die kleinen leute
auf die bühne bringen ist das dann
stammtisch oder sind das die besorgten
bürger oder gar die wutbürger wie
schätzen sie das kabarett sollte das
immer für den normalen und nicht von
oben herab ein genie man aber das sind
die zuschauer die im die vor mir sitzen
das sind nicht alles belesene spiegel
leser sondern das sind auch auf dem land
spiele ich trete ja auch auf das sind
einfache hausfrauen einfache leute das
sind bauern das sind angestellte
handwerker aldi und die probleme oder
die möchte ich auch ansprechen und nicht
nur für ein gebildetes gelesenes
publikum
besorgte bürger ist die frage wer ist
ein besorgter bürger auch dass wenn ich
mir die nachrichten anschauen magazine
anschauen die presse gucke dann unsere
medien die bringen so viel es gibt
studien und umfragen und was alles
negativ ist die kinder sind zu dick und
die spielen zu viel im internet und dann
wird wieder eine studie darüber gemacht
und darüber das ist soll man da nicht
nur besorgte bürger sein wenn ich die
nachrichten verfolge bis jetzt zu maßen
und wann weiß ich was die politik dann
kann man doch eigentlich nur besorgt
sein also diese anführungszeichen
besorgten bürgers weil ironisch klingen
ich habe nichts dagegen wenn bürger sich
sorgen machen also das ist es ja wohl
nicht mehr ist noch einen ersatz
aufgefallen in diesem ausschnitt denn
wir da gehört haben
ich komme mir schon vor wie in der ddr
ist das wirklich so was die meinung dass
war dort bezogen auf die meinung ja da
haben die ostdeutschen oder ich sage mal
so die die ddr lange kennen meine
generation so drumherum
eine erfahrung und vielleicht auch einen
besonderen draht und hören sensibel hin
wenn sie merken hier werde ich
manipuliert hier soll ich etwas zu sagen
oder so denken hier werde ich wo ihn da
das ist eine antenne
wahrscheinlich ist dass das aber auch
mit dem osten kein zufall also ich will
ich jetzt nicht selber in diese schiene
geraten dass ich sage so was darf man
doch nicht sagen aber ich würde sie
trotzdem jetzt noch mal fragen ob das in
ordnung ist dass sie die situation der
meinungsfreiheit in der bundesrepublik
deutschland im vergleich ziehen mit
einer diktatur wieder ddr
nein ich habe ja gesagt ich komme mir so
vor ich fühle mich nämlich wenn solche
sachen wie silvester köln passieren dass
die medien sagen wir müssen erst was
prüfen und berichten tage später drüber
oder es werden dinge ausgeklammert und
nicht benannt weil sie vielleicht nicht
in einem bild passen dann fühlt fühle
ich mich das ist ein bisschen
manipulativ wie in der ddr
das heißt nicht in der ddr konnte ich
vieles noch nicht sagen wurde dann
benachteiligt indem ich abgeholt wurde
oder vorgeführt wurde
das ist ja jetzt hier nicht so das würde
ich so nicht gleich so aber ein gefühl
stellt sich ein fachmann sagt warum ist
das jetzt ein problem warum soll ich
jetzt dahin gelenkt werden warum laufen
magazin oder talkshows oder sendungen so
ab was das soll was mit mir machen
also ich versuche zu verstehen wie sieht
das meinen sie haben das gefühl sie
werden da in eine bestimmte richtung
geschoben oder es ist einseitig oder was
was lösten die auswahl ist aus das ist
eben das ist dass das die tendenz da ist
ist es ist also rechtsradikal alles was
ab weil wenn du nicht so denkst wie ich
wenn du nicht diese meinung hast wie ich
dann so richtig weg dann wird
unterschieden in gut und böse und nicht
verstehen dass dieses wird unterschieden
das ist du musst so denken du hast so zu
denken wie ich dann bist du auf der
richtigen seite lassen sie uns mal auf
die aktuelle politik schauen
die letzten wochen waren bestimmt von
den ereignissen in chemnitz was ist denn
ihrer ansicht nach der schief gelaufen
chemnitz ist schief gelaufen das
berichtet es ging um das um die hetzjagd
das ist ja wohl der dreh und angelpunkt
an den selbst herr maßen nun jetzt
verlauf nimmt ob es sich um eine
hetzjagd handelt oder nicht
es gibt wohl kein richtiges verfügbares
material was diese hetzjagd wohl belegt
das ist ja wohl dreh und angelpunkt
dieser ganzen diskussion
oder es gibt sehr wenig material ich
habe videos gesehen da haben männer in
hitler gruß gezeigt und ihre hosen
hinten ausgezogen also das reicht mir zu
sehen das ist widerlich des nazi zeigt
das ist ganz ganz schlimm
ob es eine hetzjagd ist kann ich war
auch nicht dabei ich kann das nicht
sagen wenn so eine stimmung gegen
ausländer vollzogen wird ist es schlimm
genug zu sagen stopp und aus wenn es
pogrom und hetzjagd gibt dann hätte ich
auch erwartet dass frau merkel aber ganz
schnell nach chemnitz fährt oder der
bundespräsident und sagt was ist denn
hier los das ist ja kommt ja fast wie
einem anschlag gleich zu sagen wenn
pogrom und hetzjagd auf auf ausländer
stattfinden ist aber wirklich hier
schluss und da hätte ich als souffleuse
merkel gesagt fahr hin
das ist ganz wichtig dort aufzutauchen
und auch eierwerfern sich entgegen zu
rennen da sehe ich immer das bild wie
kult auch mal cindy eierwerfer reihen
lief und zu sagen im moment das will ich
jetzt hier wissen und klären da ist
nichts passiert gar nichts
ok falls die einzige die mal nach
chemnitz gefahren ist es ist für mich
ein fehler von frau merkel auch ganzen
moser fehler haben sie denn das gefühl
dass das die politik die öffentlichkeit
zu wenig verständnis demgegenüber
ausgedrückt hat die da zum beispiel in
den trauermärschen mitgelaufen sind es
wird alles vermischt
es ist vermischt sich so das sind nazis
dabei da ist afd dabei da sind
provokateure dabei und dann sind ganz
normale bürger dabei die suchen ihr
forum wo können wir das ausdrücken und
ist es so wenn neben mir jemand läuft
und hitlergruß zeigen und ausländer raus
schreit hätte ich null bock da nun mit
zu gehen würde ich sagen moment das ist
nicht mein worum also das land nicht
sein
es gibt ein video habe ich mal gesehen
da gibt es ein ordner der sich richtig
gegen die stellt und nimmt sich 1
verbringst und schreit den einen hier
wird kein hitler gruß gezeigt und die
haben
applaudiert die sachsen das wurde gar
nicht so publik gemacht da war ich was
ich guck wie toll das also chemnitzer
sagen nee mit denen wollen wenn ich in
einen topf geworfen haben ist vermischt
sich alle so die selber sagen die
chemnitzer ja wir können ja nicht wissen
wer sich dieser demo anschließt
schließen sie sich den nazis an oder die
nazis dieser demo ist vermischt sich so
wahnsinnig und menschen die sagen wir
wollen sagen und passt das nicht haben
keinen namen forum google deshalb ist
das sind sie selber 667 sind in leipzig
aufgewachsen und ich hab das jetzt ja
auch ein bisschen so raus gehört aus dem
was sie da gesagt haben das stimmt gar
nicht so wie wir sachsen wie wir da
dargestellt wurden in der presse also es
gibt ja schon einen sehr weit
verbreiteten eindruck
ok die sachsen sind besonders
fremdenfeindlich und da in sachsen
vielleicht sogar in allen neuen
bundesländern gibt es ein
rechtsextremismus problem ein ganz
spezielles
das ist eben die sachsen sind
fremdenfeindlich dass das glaube ich
nicht das ist nicht so ich glaube auch
nicht dass generell alle bundesbürger
fremdenfeindlich sind ich halte also
würde ich vor kurzem habe ich auch
gesagt das ist dass wir ein ganz toller
anthes aufgeschlossenes volk sind und da
bin ich stolz drauf das ist toll
ich glaube auch nicht dass die sachsen
jetzt sagen wir wollen keine ausländer
fremde das sind einzelne das ist ein
bodensatz die sich ganz gruselig äußern
ganz schlimm ganz grässlich und das muss
man so benennen aber dass jetzt alle
sachsen ausländern
sie möchten ein problem und das ist
sicher das problem einer ungeordneten
zuwanderung und einer ohnmacht wie geht
das weiter tausend fragen die wir haben
und die nie beantwortet wurden nicht
durch geschaffen dass sondern keiner
sondern es war immer pöbel packt dann
heizt man das natürlich an diese ganze
spirale
wie will man diese menschen wieder
gewinnen wie will man sagen wir mal
nicht afd
wenn nur noch die afg zuhört wie
gruselig ist das also dann vergeben wir
uns ja eben die chance und das wird eben
vermischt und wenn dann ein spiegel oder
gesagt da muss man wieder eine mauer
drum machen um die sachsen das heißt das
problem hatte das ist doch
nicht das miteinander reden gibt es eine
journalistin die geht dann in die demo
enthält das mikro sachsen vor die nase
auf so einer angeheizten demo kann man
nicht diskutieren guter
ministerpräsident hat das in dem extra
form hat dann auch diskussionen glaube
ich teilgenommen und da wurde auch eins
zu eins beantwortet aber das ist jetzt
schon es ist schon ein bisschen
verfahren das ist schon lange lange
sodass man dunkel deutschland gesagt hat
das ist und außerdem kommen auch viele
nazis mit den bussen herangekarrt nach
sachsen nehmen da teil
und ich habe im programm auch eine
sequenz wo ich sage gibt es im osten
menschen die ausländer hassen aber hallo
gibt es im westen weniger der sachse
puls eben lieber raus also das ist nur
dem kollegen flüsterten also ich glaube
es ist nicht nur einen sachsen problem
kommt das ja klar raus ist stamme aus
sachsen das ist auch wichtig welches
bild ist davon sachsen gibt sie sind
klar in der ddr in leipzig aufgewachsen
waren glaube ich 26 jahre alt als die
mauer gefallen ist
welchen eindruck welches gefühl hatten
sie denn in der ddr als sie da
aufgewachsen sind
das ist eine also wir mal so ich habe
meine schule kindergarten die ausbildung
die lehre studium eigentlich die
wichtigste zeit in so einer entwicklung
in der ddr genommen und das war gut ich
hatte eine schöne schulausbildung ich
hatte eine tolle lehrausbildung und ein
großartiges studium und das alles ohne
geld bis zum führerschein machen und ich
finde ich viel geld und vergleicht
sollte eigentlich toll und im richtigen
moment nämlich etwa ist das berufsleben
anfing kam die wende so dass ich mich
dann frei schwimmen konnte kurz kurz vor
der wende sind sie noch eingetreten ins
leipziger kabarett die pfeffermühle
das war dann schon die schlussphase der
ddr trotzdem die frage wie frei konnte
kameras seien in der ddr
es wurden programme geschrieben und
vorgeführt vor der premiere da saß dann
eine kommission der partei drinnen und
hat gesagt die nummer nicht das geht
nicht das überarbeiten oder das flag
fliegt ganz raus es gibt programme sogar
die wurden ganz abgesagt die waren
einstudiert und die eu kamen nicht zur
aufführung und zur wendezeit war sehr
spannend
die straße natürlich viel aktueller war
als die kabarettisten auf der bühne
da brannte die luft auf der straße und
da mussten die sich auch finden im
kabarett wir müssen auch gucken wie
wollen wir jetzt weiter arbeiten um
leute wieder in den zuschauern zu
kriegen ihn ist der sprung ins kabarett
sehr sehr gut gelungen anders als den
meisten anderen aus kabarettisten sie
waren die erste ostdeutsche die bei
dieter hildebrandt im scheibenwischer
aufgetreten ist sie wandern lange jahre
ensemblemitglied in der münchner lach
und schießgesellschaft wie ist in dieser
systemwechsel genommen also bislang war
so leichter als manchen menschen der ddr
die völlig anderen beruf nehmen mussten
weil in der ddr nach ende der ddr ist
diesen zu lesen dieses kombinat dem
betrieb nicht mehr gab oder den völlig
neuen job da hatte ich einfach bühne ist
bühne das ist auf der ganzen welt so
sich vor leute zu stellen und was zu
machen ist selber es ging inhaltlich
darum wir hatten dann der andere themen
und hier ging es um rhein main donau
kanal wird weiß ich um parteien und
viele parteien was wir in der ddr hatten
das war eine umstellung inhaltlich die
art des zu machen und zu präsentieren
blieb gleich für mich noch der grössere
sprung war es dann nach dem nach der
lach und schießgesellschaft vom ensemble
spielerin zur solistin zu werden das
heißt also selber auch texte zu machen
mich mehr einzumischen verantwortlich
für mein produkt zu zeigen und nicht im
ensemble somit zu schwimmen das ist ein
viel für mich größerer schritt gewesen
und ist in diesen ganzen jahren mit den
programmen auch eine souffleuse das zu
entwickeln bis zum heutigen moment zu
sagen du warst die kanzlersouffleuse und
jetzt ist es wohl zeit zu kündigen und
zu gehen und nach neuem zu gucken und
das werde ich wird spannend wie die
nächsten programme sind wir haben das ja
schon mehrfach angesprochen
das kabarett in deutschland ist meistens
links und sie machen aus doch eine ganz
andere haltung kabarett was man sich
irgendwo toll weil dadurch haben sie
eine sonderstellung
haben sie manchmal auch das gefühl
menschen ich bin da ganz schön der
außenseiterin in der branche
ich kenne nicht die programme aller
kollegen ich glaube es gibt noch mehr
kollegen die das auch so machen aber ich
frage mich bin ich rechts oder links das
können ja andere entscheiden ich sage so
wie ich jetzt fühle und wie mehr ist und
klopfen mich jetzt nicht ab ob es rechts
links ist können andere entscheiden
wollen sie da was bewirkt wenn sie
kabarett machen oder ist schon okay wenn
sie einfach gut unterhalten also wichtig
ist dass ich gut unterhalte deshalb
kommen die leute auch und geben geld aus
also es sollen sehr lustig sein es soll
humorig sein weil ich gerne lacher und
mich mit humor sehr gern beschäftigen
und das ist auch der charme und witz die
politik humoristisch zu sehen ich bin ja
keine journalistin
aber wenn die menschen nach hause gehen
und auf dem heimweg sich noch sätze
erinnern oder abend beim zähneputzen
sagt guck mal das hatte jedoch gesagt
jetzt sehe ich dass in den nachrichten
heiko maas oder merkel oder guck mal das
hat jedoch vorher und sicher ändern
dann bin ich glücklich dann ist toll und
wenn sie dann noch eine mail schreiben
manchmal nachts gibt es viele zuschauer
die noch nachts mehr schreiben wie sie
das programm fanden und gar nicht wie
ich gespielt habe wie es früher war
sondern inhaltlich jetzt was zu meinem
inhalt sagen zu einer politischen
haltung auch das ist toll also ich meine
wo gibts was besseres ich kann den
glückspilz das war völlig persönlich
heute mit der kabarettistin simone solga
herzlichen dank
[Musik]